in this video i'll be showing you all
the secrets for how to fish
in animal crossing new horizons this is
a video that will be great for beginners
of the game who want to know more about
one of the most popular activities in
animal crossing it's also a great way to
make bells
we'll start out covering the basics of
fishing how to catch different types of
fish
and then an extra special tip on a
unique way to use
fish bait and we're starting right now
people of the international retro
raccoon tour here and welcome back to
another animal crossing new horizons
video
if you guys are new here we post two
gaming videos each week and if you enjoy
the video today i'd love for you to
subscribe to the channel
but only if you love the video of course
so where do we begin with
fishing well for starters it's been one
of the most popular activities since all
the way back to the original animal
crossing game for the nintendo gamecube
and personally it's one of my favorite
things to do in the game
it's relatively simple to get started
with fishing but it can be difficult to
fully master don't worry we're going to
cover it all here today
first you'll need to obtain a fishing
rod you can either purchase one at
nook's cranny using bells or you can
craft one instead
you'll get the flimsy fishing rod diy
recipe from tom nook fairly early in the
game
if you don't have it yet just keep
completing your objectives from tom nook
and when he lets you know about a free
crafting workshop
make sure you take him up on the offer
the flimsy fishing rod is fairly easy to
craft as it only requires five tree
branches
just walk around shaking trees until you
get five this particular rod will break
after catching just 10 fish but don't
worry
you'll unlock better options as you
continue to play through the game
once you have your fishing rod head over
to any body of water and start looking
for fish
you'll want to make sure you walk
instead of run because running often
scares fish away
they come in several different shadow
sizes some have fins and some are
longer and thinner these shadow sizes
are really only important when you're
going after
a specific fish but more on that in just
a bit
for now position yourself in front of
the shadow and press
a to cast your line if it's not anywhere
close to the fish's mouth then press
a again to just reel it back in you can
then reposition
and cast again this can take a little
bit to get used to but eventually you'll
start to understand the angles and be
able to position yourself just right on
the first or second try
once you get the fishing line in the eye
side of the fish wait
do not press a and attempt to reel back
you'll see the fish get closer
and closer and then start to nibble
you'll know it's nibbling because of the
little bobber in the water
now this is where things get interesting
sometimes the fish will bite immediately
other times they'll take a few nibbles
first what you're really looking for is
the bobber going
all the way under a stronger vibration
from your controller
and a slightly different sound as the
bobber goes down
under the water
as soon as this happens press and hold a
keep holding the button until you reel
in the fish and congratulations you just
caught your first fish
fishing and animal crossing is purely
about timing
if you're quick enough pressing a you'll
catch the fish every time
press it too early or too late though
and you'll lose out on the fish
it's a pretty simple process but you
should know that rare fish usually
require more precise
timing to be honest the easiest way to
catch the fish
is to close your eyes no i'm serious
close your eyes
at least once you have the bobber in
their line of sight closing your eyes
actually helps in a few different ways
first this removes the element of you
possibly getting faked out by a fish
just going in for a nibble now you're
just listening for the special water
kerplunk sound that only happens when
the fish bites
it sounds like this
and believe it or not the sound actually
comes ever so slightly before
the visual indicator with the bobber
going underwater
some people don't have any trouble at
all either way but if you find yourself
frequently missing some of the rare fish
you may want to try the closing your
eyes trick as someone who's been fishing
in animal crossing games for years i
have to say it's honestly
easier to close your eyes when you're
doing the fishing now when it comes to
catching different types of fish there
are two things you need to know
the first thing is that many fish are
seasonal in animal crossing
meaning they're only available to catch
during certain months of the year
the animal crossing fandom wiki is a
great place to see this information
i also put out a little guide each month
to help you quickly see all the new fish
you can find it on my twitter account or
in my discord
i'll put a link to all of these down in
the description below
but it's not just about seasonality the
fish
also spawn in specific locations and at
specific times of the day
there's the sea rivers and ponds there
are also
additional special locations such as the
pier river mouth
clifftop rivers and clifftop ponds
all of this information is also in the
monthly guide i post
as well as on the wiki so if you're
looking to catch every fish you'll need
to get comfortable with
all the locations in the game as well as
knowing which fish you can catch
during specific months and specific
times of the day
if you only play at a certain time each
day let's say in the morning
then you'll have to change your play
habits to catch fish that only spawn
during the evening hours
or you can always time travel if that's
something you're okay with doing
you'll most likely want to donate new
fish to your museum first
but fish are also a great way to make
bells especially when cj comes to town
as he'll pay you 50 percent more than
the same fish at nook's cranny
now with so many rare fish only spawning
at specific locations
you'll want to get familiar with fish
bait you can craft one fish bait for
every one manila clam you find
on the beach these are the little
shadows you see fairly often in the sand
now i mentioned an extra special tip
regarding fish bait and
something i only learned just recently
despite playing the game
since launch okay so first the basics of
fish bait they're pretty simple
walk up to any body of water toss it out
and a fish will appear
from there it's basically what we talked
about before but let's say you're going
after a specific fish like a blue marlin
now the blue marlin only spawns at the
pier as a huge
shadow so if you throw out fish baiting
at a small shadow there's really no
point in catching that fish
now what i would used to do is i would
run around scared away and then use
another fish bait very often though
using this method it would give me the
exact
same fish and also take up extra time
but here's the trick instead of scaring
the fish away just throw out another
fish
bait with the fish already there
the bait hitting the water will scare
that fish away and a new fish will still
spawn in
of course you use a lot more bait this
way but if you're going after a specific
fish this method is far
more time efficient after you catch all
the fish in the game you'll get the diy
recipe for the golden fishing rod
no you will not see me with the golden
fishing rod just yet because at the time
i'm recording this video
it's currently impossible to obtain the
fishing rod without
time traveling and i'm not a time
traveler no worries if you are though
you do you i mentioned earlier how i
hoped you'd subscribed if you enjoyed
the video
so if you want to see more animal
crossing content like this hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
ring the notification
bell also if you're a beginner i have
prepared a full
animal crossing beginners playlist that
i'll link to here on the right side of
your page
be sure and check it out thanks so much
for watching i'll talk to you again soon